good morning John it's Wednesday Oh Oh
cheer would you say it's Wednesday it's
question Wednesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
number one what was your biggest
childhood argument I think that you
lying is the problem where you where
something would happen you would lie and
I would get blamed because you were
better liar than I was you're still a
much better liar than I am I'm a
novelist
yeah it's like my job how come you guys
never come to Ireland or even mention it
mentioned done would you rather have a
unicorn or a Pegasus a Pegasus obviously
no yeah house wings so if you had a
unicorn you could kill it you could kill
the Pegasus too if you wanted to you can
ride a unicorn it's like it's just a
freaking horse it's like would you
rather have a horse or a flying horse is
it possible that the giant squid of
anger and the Tsar walk from star wars
share an evolutionary link no it's not
because that happened in a galaxy far
far away and there's no way to transmit
genetic material between galaxies it's
also a long time ago right that's not
that's not as big of a problem it's more
the far far away yeah why does the
internet love bacon so because bacon is
delicious
yeah bacon is good for me do you ever
see those uh those those anti-piracy ads
that are like you wouldn't download
bacon and I'm like yes I would it is
possible that is bad things because we
can download bacon hahaha
does it come out of my printer what's
your favorite thing about each other I
like this part yeah totally creepy
yeah just inspired a very unfortunate
generation of fan fiction writers I
think there's gonna be a Facebook fan
page for this part what's up I was
giving them some of that part Oh
so that they could make it make their
screen ban something up on my ceiling oh
you Kermit up there he's just you know
my household god I mean when I have
that's where I have Padre Pio I have a
Roman Catholic saint and you have Kermit
I figured Padre Pio was a soccer player
ha ha ha ha ha ha just assumed have you
seen the new modernized version of
Sherlock Holmes are we talking about the
Cumberbatch one or the the Downey jr.
one because the compel the Cumberbatch
one two thumbs up yes the Downey junior
one one thumb
yeah see we don't don't disability arm
wrestling match
Oh Rosalie match one two three
thank you look like oh you guys go back
and watch your old videos that implies
that we've ever watched an old video I
never what you never watch brother 2.0
I've never seen the show I really enjoy
watching the old videos particularly
your old videos when I watch my old
videos I'm pretty hard on myself funny
because I like to watch my old videos
too haha my big is so funny oh my god
why do you do the things you do wouldn't
it be easier to just play games all day
what is the point of doing things in
general that's it what is the point of
doing things in general there is no
reason to do there's no like cosmic
mandate to do stuff I feel bad for that
person because I've struggled with that
a lot in fact I wrote a novel about it
called The Fault in Our Stars it's all
about a link below all copies will be
signed since there isn't as you said a
cosmic mandate to do things you know
there isn't a cosmic mandate to make
stuff and the world probably won't be
any different as a result of the stuff
that you make or do I think it's human
nature I think that we have a human
nature to like to do stuff and interact
with people and and to make the world
better for each other I don't that we
like doing that yeah making stuff is
very fulfilling in and of itself in a
way to even make video game is art and
better if it's making I mean even you
know video games are set up to do that
they're set up to satisfy that need
right but they can also become kind of
insular right no I mean they're set up
to satisfy that need in a very shallow
way we love making awesome stuff with
awesome people that's what we've always
loved and we feel very lucky to be part
of a community where that stuff happens
I'm going to turn that right there into
a song are you in a song is it gonna be
called making awesome stuff with awesome
people oh you're gonna song if I mean
I'm gonna sing on key for once I can't
act I do not have that technology haha
John thank you for doing my first
question Tuesday ever with me it's been
a privilege and I will see you right now
I will continue to see you stop looking
at me stop looking at me